ist natürlich völlig klar dass es vor
allen dingen auch um corona geht und um
das impfen das spielt auch hier eine
rolle am heutigen tage der bundestag hat
seine regeln verschärft zweig plus gilt
jetzt auch für die abgeordneten für uns
journalisten für alle besucher dieses
hauses und das bedeutet für den ein oder
anderen abgeordneten der gar nicht
geimpft ist er soll sich testen lassen
damit er weniger auf der tribüne platz
nehmen kann und da gibt es tatsächlich
welche die das nicht wollen und gar
nicht mehr ins haus rein kommen das wird
hier sicherlich nachher gleich auch
diskutiert werden wir erwarten eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte dazu aber
lassen sie uns noch mal auf olaf scholz
gucken eigentlich hätte er vor
weihnachten hier schon sich den fragen
stellen sollen der war aber gerade als
frisch gewählter kann es da wirklich
beschäftigt auch mit auslands terminen
das hat die opposition eingesehen und
deswegen kommt er heute zu den
abgeordneten man könnte natürlich auch
mutmaßen was für fragen gestellt werden
und als journalist hat man ohnehin immer
sehr viele fragen eine frage die ich mir
stelle ist zum beispiel nicht nur bei
olaf scholz sondern bei allen spitzen
politikern in diesem land bis kurz nach
der bundestagswahl waren eigentlich alle
gegen eine impfpflicht auf einmal sind
alle für eine impfpflicht das kann einen
schon irritieren und das was die
virologen dazu sagen täglich neu in den
nachrichten zu erleben ist ja auch immer
sehr ein sehr großes durcheinander
insofern wäre es sinnvoll dass die
bundesregierung da die führung übernimmt
und sagt wo es langgeht olaf scholz hat
das auch gemacht bei seiner
regierungserklärung hat gesagt das ist
chefsache dann ist er da so ein bisschen
zurück gerudert verständlicherweise
wahrscheinlich würde er keine mehrheit
kriegen in seiner ampelkoalition wir
haben es mitbekommen bei der fdp gibt es
viele kritiker es gibt ja auch schon
einen gruppenantrag der sagt wir wollen
überhaupt keine impfpflicht von einem
fdp von mehreren fdp abgeordneten also
eine schwierige gemengelage und die
spd-bundestagsfraktion hat jetzt den
druck ein wenig aus dem kessel gelassen
gestern abend sie hat nämlich gesagt wir
wollen eine orientierungs debatte ende
des monats und dann legen wir auch ein
konzept vor einen antrag und da frage
ich gleich mal meine gäste zu dir wie
sie begrüße ich ganz herzlich er ist der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd-bundestagsfraktion genau der
richtige mann für diesen bereich und
thorsten frei ist für alle bereiche
zuständig als neuer erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion herr wiese
ich hab gesagt
oder stolz sagt das soll das parlament
entscheiden
ein bisschen überraschen denn er hatte
er gesagt verfügung gestellt kann auch
führungen bekommen warum lehnt er ab
einen gesetzesantrag selber zu
formulieren mit seinem
gesundheitsminister der jetzt hinter den
kulissen als abgeordneter lauterbach
diesen gruppen antrag formuliert das
versteht doch kein mensch mehr ist eine
schließt das andere nicht aus wir haben
uns allerdings bewusst dazu entschieden
die es zu einer ethischen frage zu
machen ich halte das auch für richtig
ich glaube jeder abgeordnete muss frei
nach seinem gewissen weil dieser nicht
einfachen frage dann auch der eine
entscheidung herbeizuführen wir haben
gesagt wir wollen das herbeiführen im
ersten quartal das heißt im laufe des
märz auch zu einer entscheidung zu
kommen wir werden genau wie sie es
gesagt haben eine orientierungs debatte
ende januar führen es wird sicherlich
nicht bei dem antrag von wolfgang
kubicki bleiben es wird sicherlich
mehrere anträge letztendlich auch geben
aber nochmal man muss diese debatte
jetzt gründlich führen ich halte das für
richtig sie als eine gewissensfrage hier
auch zu diskutieren aber wir werden da
auch sehr zügig zu einer entscheidung
kommen und noch mal das ist auch eine
führung letztendlich das hier auch als
parlament zu machen und dass so eine
verantwortung für uns als deutsche
bundestag er frei sie hatten gestern
eine offene debatte in der
bundestagsfraktion da waren auch
experten spezialisten haben sie sich
denn eine meinung machen können gibt es
ein einheitliches meinungsbild bei der
union also zunächst einmal will ich
sagen dass ob die frage eine
gewissensentscheidung ist letztlich
nicht im kanzleramt und auch nicht in
den fraktionsführungen entschieden wird
sondern entscheidet jeder abgeordnete
für sich und ich finde selbst wenn man
das annehmen würde entbindet es die
bundesregierung nicht in der
schwierigsten frage und der größten
krise derzeit führung zu übernehmen und
für das was sie selber für richtig und
notwendig erachtet auch einen
gesetzgebungsvorschlag zu machen der
zweite punkt ist wenn die
bundesregierung dies schon nicht macht
dann müssen wir uns natürlich intensiv
mit dem thema auseinander setzen wir
haben deswegen schon vor weihnachten
zahlreiche fragen an die bundesregierung
gerichtet die bis dato nicht beantwortet
sind weil es ist ja keine schwarz-weiß
entscheidung bist du für die impfpflicht
oder bist du dagegen sondern es sind
eine ganze reihe von fragen die sich
immer dem ziel unterordnen müssen was
müssen wir tun um dauerhaft das
gesundheitswesen nicht zu überlasten und
da kann eine impfpflicht eine hilfreiche
hilfreicher teil der lösung sein aber
dafür brauchen wir grundständige
medizinisch-technische aber auch
juristische antworten auf die
herausforderungen
das klingt schon wesentlich
zurückhaltender als das gestern oder
vorgestern auch von seiten der cdu csu
kam aber nochmal auf die
entscheidungsfindung die hier ansteht
kommt ihm nicht viel zu spät wir haben
jetzt die mikrowelle und ich habe
gestern mit überraschung gehört dass die
führenden politiker im haus in dem fall
war es die grüne fraktionsvorsitzende
gesagt hat ja also für diese welle lohnt
sich das sowieso nicht wir machen es
dann für die nächste aber es gibt ja
noch gar keinen impfstoff gegen nikon
wie will man denn vorweg schauen welche
mutationen kommt und welchen impfstoff
will man bis dahin war impfen herr diese
muss ich einmal widersprechen also alle
expertinnen und experten sagen dass wenn
man jetzt gepustet ist dies wohl sehr
gut auch auf die aktuelle nikon variante
schützt darum will ich nochmal bestärken
wie wichtig es ist diese wusste rung
durchzuführen und auch diejenigen die
sich noch nicht entschieden haben zu
impfen sich auch impfen zu lassen also
der schutz ist dadurch auch vorhanden
letztendlich es ist allerdings richtig
und das haben auch expertinnen und
experten immer wieder gesagt auch
professor drosten dass eine impfpflicht
nicht kurzfristig wirkt ich glaube jetzt
wird der instrumentenkasten den wir als
ampel im rahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes auf den weg
gebracht haben er hat auch schon bei der
delta variante gewirkt das hat sich in
den letzten wochen auch gezeigt die
impfpflicht ist etwas perspektivisch für
den kommenden herbst und winter darum
ist es richtig diese debatte jetzt
gründlich zu führen aber nochmal ich
halte es für realistisch im ersten
quartal zu einem ergebnis zu kommen ich
lade auch die kolleginnen und kollegen
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion sind
restrukturierungskosten auch
einzubringen dass wir eine breite
debatte im parlament haben gemeinsam am
gruppen anträgen aber nochmal wenn man
die entscheidung in das parlament gibt
die abgeordneten letztendlich über die
fraktionsgrenzen hinaus antworten finden
sollen dann ist es richtig dass das
parlament das macht die bundesregierung
zu liefert mit diesem weg haben wir uns
jetzt entschieden zu beschreiten für
frei wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe gruppenanträge werden jetzt auch
von ihnen dann freigegeben für ihre
abgeordneten denn ich kenne den einen
oder anderen bei der union der auch
durchaus sehr skeptisch ist und sich
vielleicht sogar herrn kubicki
anschließen will das weiß ich nicht aber
noch mal die frage die ich ja eben schon
gestellt habe sahra wagenknecht zum
beispiel sagt warum soll es eine
zwangsimpfung geben wenn die impfstoffe
die jetzt verkauft werden im grunde
genommen gegen die mutationen die gerade
im umlauf ist omikron überhaupt nicht
helfen denn man erkrankt ja an dieser
krankheit vielleicht nicht so schwer wie
andere das scheint so zu sein aber man
ist ja von einigen auch ansteckend für
andere also im grunde genommen diese
ganze bus 3 in allen ehren die schützt
einen bestenfalls selber das anders das
kann eben auch helfen um die überlastung
des gesundheitswesens zu verhindern das
ist sozusagen das übergeordnete ziel
aber sie haben ja selber angesprochen
das sind ja ganz viele fragen ungeklärt
wenn sie eine impfpflicht machen für wen
auch immer dann müssen sie das
durchsetzen und die frage wie sie das
machen ist ungeklärt wir haben kein
nationales imf register aus der
koalition hören sie stimmen die dafür
sind und solche die dagegen sind die
frage was passiert wenn sie sich nicht
impfen lassen welche konsequenzen hat
das das muss alles beantwortet werden
genauso wie die medizinischen fragen die
sie angesprochen haben damit man die
frage beantworten kann ob dieser
grundrechtseingriff der es ohne zweifel
wäre auch zum erwarteten ziel führt und
das haben wir noch nicht ich möchte
ihnen auch insoweit widersprechen also
wir sind wir haben die core die die
fraktionsinterne meinungsbildung noch
nicht abgeschlossen
deswegen gibt es auch keine beteiligung
unserer abgeordneten an diskussionen
über gruppenanträge sondern wenn wir
etwas tun dann tun wir es als fraktion
denn ich will noch mal wieder
wiederholen die frage einer
gewissensentscheidung heißt ja nicht
dass eine regierung einen vorschlag
macht wie sie es machen möchte dass am
ende das parlament entscheidet das haben
wir bei jedem gesetz das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber
regierungsverantwortung hat halt auch
was mit verantwortung zu tun und dieser
verantwortung muss die bundesregierung
nachkommen wie sind sie für ein im free
gäste
es gibt fragen die jetzt in der
laufenden debatte noch beantwortet
werden müssen ich will aber sehr
deutlich sagen dass für die einführung
einer allgemeinen pflicht kein ins
register erforderlich ist es gibt
expertinnen und experten die sagen dass
man dies auch anders hinbekommen kann
ohne erst an im register einzuführen und
ein punkt der mich bezüglich eines im
register sehr skeptisch macht ist es
braucht eine gewisse zeit dieses
register auch aufzubauen dieses register
sozusagen
scharf zu stellen österreich haben
letztes jahr damit angefangen die werden
ab nächsten monat diese impfpflicht
haben haben ein komplettes im register
hat da die vorgängerregierung an der sie
auch beteiligt waren was versäumt nein
dann an dem punkt definitiv nicht und
noch mal man kann eine allgemeine
impfpflicht auch ohne eigenes register
einführen das ist möglich und von daher
wir werden entsprechende vorschläge
jetzt intensivieren in der debatte mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen dann auch
interpretieren aber noch mal es ist
nicht zwingend erforderlich für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht an dem register
zu herr frei das ist schon mal der erste
punkt wo ich mich frage wie will man das
dann kontrollieren wenn man keinen
frieden hat der weiterer punkt ist was
will man den menschen eigentlich
vorschreiben soll man jede drei monate
jede sechs monaten eine impfung kriegen
da gibt es noch viele offene fragen die
überhaupt nicht geklärt sind ja also
genauso sage ich es ja auch es sind
viele fragen die zu beantworten sind
damit man auch eine verfassungskonforme
und auch eine ethisch verantwortbare
lösung am ende hat und anders als der
krise bin ich der auffassung dass man
dringend ein impf register benötigt zum
einen hier in diesem fall aber ich
glaube dass es für unser land wichtig
wäre auch für die zukunft auch für
zukünftige herausforderungen ein solches
register zu haben denn sie haben
natürlich vollkommen recht wenn wir
nicht wissen wer in deutschland geimpft
ist wird man eine impfpflicht auch nicht
durchsetzen können man wird sie
jedenfalls nicht so durchsetzen können
dass man die impfquote in der
bevölkerung auf 85 auf 90 oder mehr
prozent steigern wird können und wenn
man das nicht kann dann wird man das
ziel verfehlen und daran müssen wir uns
orientieren eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gibt es auf der welt nur äußerst selten
so starten wie tadschikistan
indonesien mikronesien haben das und
demnächst dann auch deutschland wenn es
nach der
bundestagsfraktion spd geht es ist
sicherlich richtig dass eine impfpflicht
nicht in so vielen staaten vorhanden ist
es ist allerdings auch so dass die
korona pandemie zu anderen beurteilungen
auch führt wir haben bisher auch keine
impfpflicht gehabt jetzt gibt es viele
gute argumente dafür eine impfpflicht
auch einzuführen aber nochmal ich möchte
der orientierungs debatte nichts
vorwegnehmen die ist glaube ich wichtig
für das parlament ich strebe aber mit
der spd bundestagsfraktion und glaube
ich das ist auch der zeitplan den wir
als ampelkoalition teilen eine
entscheidung im ersten quartal dank
nochmal auf den bundeskanzler zu kommen
der nachher ja hier sich den fragen
stellt da gibt es ja noch mehr fragen
die man stellen könnte zum beispiel zur
energiepolitik die natürlich nicht nur
die einzelne menschen betrifft sondern
auch die koalitionspartner grüne und spd
ich sage nur noch zum 2 das ist ja
vollkommen ungeklärt hier in dieser
koalition
wo sehen sie da ansetzen wo man den
kanzler wo sich her treiben könnte
aussicht wir haben ja leider nur 60
minuten zeit für die befragung aber die
ganze woche und mit den einzelnen
ministern auch zu debattieren wenn man
kann vieles ansprechen da gehört die
haushalts und finanzpolitik dazu da
gehören die ersten vorschläge der
innenministerin dazu da gehört natürlich
auch die wirtschafts- und energiepolitik
dazu wo es letztlich darum geht dass man
die hohen klimapolitischen ansprüche
auch so verwirklichen kann dass sie für
die menschen auch bezahlbar sind dass
sie auch leistbar sind und deswegen
glaube ich können wir uns häufig auch in
der zielsetzung
einig werden aber der weg zum ziel da
führen unterschiedliche wege hin und das
werden wir mit sicherheit auch deutlich
machen jetzt in der kanzler- befragung
und werden die gelegenheit nutzen den
regierungschef eben auch auf den zahn zu
fühlen bei nord stream 2 hat sich der
kanzler zunächst einmal durchgesetzt mal
sehen ob das auf lange frist so bleibt
aber bei der taxonomie
komischen ausdruck der aus brüssel kam
über uns leicester dass zum beispiel die
atomkraftwerke aber die gaskraftwerke
eben als grün definiert werden und dort
privates geld rein fließen soll der hat
übrigens die eu heute eine entscheidung
getroffen und die frist ein wenig
verlängert es gab jedoch einen aufschrei
in europa aber nicht so einen großen
denen die grünen gerne sehen würden
wahrscheinlich wird es so kommen dass
diese beiden energieformen freigegeben
werden die franzosen drängen vor allem
auf die atomkraft und da hat olaf scholz
bisher sehr wenig zugesagt wird man sich
denn anstelle der bundesregierung
der klage anschließen die österreich und
luxemburg anstreben erstmal möchte ich
noch mal klar und deutlich sagen dass
auch in dieser woche ist ein wichtiges
signal ist dass olaf scholz heute den
fragen und antworten der kolleginnen und
kollegen hier zur verfügung steht in der
ersten sitzung wochen des jahres auch
dass die neuen ministerinnen und
minister ihr arbeitsprogramm
präsentieren ich glaube das ist ein
fortschritt koalitionsvertrag den wir
sehen und sicherlich das eine oder
andere was von den kolleginnen und
kollegen der oppositions kommt ist
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen der
neuen rollen finden nach 16 jahren
regierung geschuldet bei cdu/csu
nichtsdestotrotz die energiefrage ist
wesentlich ich glaube und das sage ich
auch sehr deutlich gas ist im übergang
entscheidend wenn wir bis 20 45 100
prozent erneuerbare energien haben
wollen brauchen wir etwas im übergang
dafür brauchen wir gas von daher halte
ich diese entscheidungen in den hinblick
auch für richtig wir haben auch im
koalitionsvertrag gesagt wir wollen
moderne gaskraftwerke dass die
entscheidung über die atom politik
schwierig ist das will ich einräumen
viele derjenigen befürworter die sagen
atomenergie wäre richtig die haben bis
heute nicht die frage beantwortet würde
denn dann auch ein atom endlager bei
ihnen vielleicht in ihrem
verantwortungsbereich oder in ihrem
wahlkreis sein also da gibt es viele die
das so ein bisschen vor sich her fragen
weil diese endlagerfrage nicht geklärt
ist bis heute er fahre jetzt kann ich
sie nichts mehr fahre ich habe ihnen
versprochen dass sie rechtzeitig drin
sein wenn es geht da drin nämlich jetzt
los aber die opposition kann sich eine
ruhe zurücklehnen und gucken wie sich
drei in einer regierungskoalition
manchmal auch konträr gegenüber stehen
in den nächsten tagen wochen und monate
viele der sie da habe ich setzen dann
willst du dein in den plenarsaal meine
damen und herren